ja ich bin gestern in berlin gelandet
haben mich dann natürlich gerade mit der
korona situation hier in deutschland
beschäftigt nationale lob notlage sagt
merkel wie die korona zahlen sind so
hoch wie sie es nicht waren
50.000 mehr als 50.000 heute
da denke ich schon ich meine die
deutsche regierung beschäftigt sich
jetzt schon fast zwei jahre mit dieser
krone politik und zwar sehr
schwerpunktmäßig also macht eigentlich
fast nichts anderes und jetzt ist die
lage so schlimm wie noch nie und das
muss einem schon zu denken geben und
gibt haut so ein bisschen hinweise
darauf dass dann will ich ja auch ein
schweres politisches versagen vorliegt
jetzt könnte man natürlich denken was
macht die regierung also was machen die
minister legen sie sich legen sie sich
sozusagen auf dem boden bitten um
entschuldigung selbstkritik übungen aber
auch das findet nicht statt stattdessen
wird ein anderer schuldiger gefunden und
das ist eigentlich der renitente bürger
der problembär der sich nicht impfen
lassen will der ungeimpfte und ich finde
einfach auch die rhetorik serie
interessant von von der politik also der
ehemalige bundespräsident gauck hat von
bekloppten gesprochen sie werden auf
egoisten bezeichnet es wird von einer
tyrannei der ungeimpften gesprochen und
da denke ich dann schon glaubt man
eigentlich dass man mit dieser raum
sprache die er schon fast eine
gefährderansprache ist diese leute noch
irgendwie zur impfung motivieren kann
und das ganze ist natürlich einfach auch
ein riesiges ablenkungsmanöver von
eigenen versäumnissen ich denke da an
die booster impfung die man verschlafen
habe ich denke an intensivbetten die man
wirklich absurde weise in dieser corona
pandemie sogar ob behalten nicht
aufgebaut sondern rund 4000 betten
reduziert hat
katastrophale kommunikation mit denen
man die leute nicht erreicht habt also
und all das wäre jetzt einfach so zur
seite geschoben
problembär bürger von gamestar
ja ich wundere mich ein bisschen dass
ausgerechnet der bürger jetzt schuld
sein soll wir müssen uns einfach mal
klar machen wir haben etwa 70 prozent
geimpft wir haben dann all diejenigen
die zwischenzeitlich corona gehabt haben
also genesen sind und
aus diesem pool ist jetzt sozusagen der
schulden kreis der schuldigen kreis
ermittelt worden das natürlich schon
schräg also
müssten sich eigentlich mal endlich
eingestehen dass wir das virus sehr
schwer verstehen und dass wir auch den
umgang mit der impfung noch nicht
hundertprozentig verstanden haben das
scheint politikern du weißt dass besser
immer schwer zu fallen einzugestehen
dass man irgendetwas noch nicht so ganz
durchdrungen hat aber man muss schon mal
tat zeigen wie könnte ich dem chef des
haupt studios von bild irgendwie so
gering dass hier etwas besser wirst du
als er der sich das von vielen dank gute
politik befasst dass sie du hast kennt
sich ebenso gut außerdem danke dafür
aber ich achte ja die meinung stärke von
schweizern und gerade wenn sie von einem
ganz besonderen medium kommen wieder 90
der zeitung dass ich mit viel genuss
schon seit vielen vielen jahren lese
aber in diesem punkt bin ich völlig
anderer meinung denn natürlich sind die
ungeimpften schuld an der lage die wir
haben wir den sonst mein seit 18 monaten
lesen und hören und erleben wir nichts
anderes als dass es wichtig ist sich zu
impfen dass wir wissen über die gefahren
der korona epidemie seinen 18 jahren
gibt es irgendwann dann auch gar nicht
aber wir lesen seit 18 monaten über die
gefahren und seitdem ist die impfung
gibt seit ende letzten jahres wissen wir
dass es wichtig ist sich zu impfen und
wer das nicht tut der gefährdet ja
natürlich nicht nur sich sondern
gefährdet auch viele andere und dann
kann man natürlich sagen es gibt zu
wenig intensivbetten weil die laufen
jetzt alle voll in vielen wie bayern
oder thüringen etwa wir sehen oder in
sachsen auch nur wir sind im
europäischen vergleich relativ gut
versorgt mit intensivbetten und
diejenigen die intensivbetten wären ja
gar nicht belegt wenn diejenigen die
sich impfen lassen könnten sich impfen
gelassen hätten ein drittel derer die da
liegen das sind impft durchbrüchen aber
das problem hätten wir gar nicht wenn
die zwei drittel die diese betten
belegen würden nicht da wären und sich
hätten impfen lassen also das auf die
politik abzuschieben und zu sagen ihr
seid diejenigen die verantwortlich sind
das macht es sich zu leicht im gegenteil
diejenigen die sich nicht impfen lassen
das sind die verantwortlichen für diesen
vierten lockte an denen wir haben und
die tragen die verantwortung für die
zuständigen dahinter macht man sich
schon ein bisschen zu einfach oder
sieben fern davon ording jemandem die
schuld zu geben und dieser ganzen
pandemie aber bedeutet uns ja mag sein
aber nochmal rein wenn man das sogar
immer so sieht wie kann man erwarten
dass doch so einen druck und trifft eben
dieses diese verbalen ausflug steht er
jeden tag irgendwie schlimmer werden
irgendjemanden dazu bewegt sich jetzt
impfen zu lassen also wenn in der zeit
heute ein text erscheint versteht wir
müssen jetzt die gesellschaft spalten
nämlich ernsthaft also weil wir müssen
ihn jetzt sagen was für vollidioten sie
sind jetzt finde ich es irgendwie absurd
weil auf diesem moralischen ross und da
spielt sich bürger gegen bürger aus also
eben die moralische haben an den anderen
erklären das ding wieder möbel sind
anstatt zu schauen was eben in der
politik schief gelaufen ist weil ich als
doppelt impfte kann mir eigentlich noch
nicht mal wirklich postern lassen gehen
außerdem können wir ihnen wie selbst
drum und finde irgend ein arzt das jetzt
schon macht also da wird noch einiges
auf uns zukommen und ich glaube da gibt
es mehr hinzuschauen als jetzt den
finger auf die anzurichten und ich finde
schon ich meine es gibt natürlich einen
eigenen verantwortung style natürlich
ist es wünschenswert dass sich die
bürger impfen aber ich glaube das ist
einfach ein teil die eigenverantwortung
der bürger aber es gibt auch die
verantwortung der regierung und die hat
eben auch massive fehler gemacht ich
denke da an die booster impfung ich
meine warum hat man damit nicht schon
ich meine gewisse ältere leute die waren
schon durchgeimpft irgendwie im januar
warum hat man nicht im august oder im
september damit angefangen denen eine
dritten punkt zu geben ist das ist ein
politisch ja aber sie wollen ja
sozusagen sagen die schuldigen sind
einfach die umgehenden regierung hat
einen tollen job gemacht da sehe ich
natürlich komplett anders ja nicht
wieder einmal kurz dagegen wollte sage
ich ja nicht die sage ich die regierung
hat einen tollen job gemacht natürlich
hat auch die regierung fehler gemacht
als jede noch mal hört man einfach
entspannen deshalb die sich ja
untereinander als entspannen die
dänische lage zu für beendet erklärt hat
im oktober war das natürlich ein fehler
dass das ein fehler war hat ihm dann
markus söder im deutschlandfunk
vorgehalten aber wir erleben natürlich
auch dass die ampel jetzt quasi die
verantwortlichen sind die zustände die
sie noch nicht mehr zu verantworten
haben das ist ja auch etwas völlig
anderes was hier gespielt wird also die
verantwortung ist schon bei den zu
suchen wenn man es überhaupt politisch
sieht bei denen die bisher verantwortung
getragen haben und das ist die bisherige
und auch geschäftsführende regierung mit
allen die dazu gehören aber ich bleibe
dabei die regierung natürlich gibt es
fehler bei den postern oder als auf
einmal aus der aus dem blauen heraus
aber ich habe festgestellt dass wir
ungefähr vier millionen neugierige
hatten dass wir auch im titel die
abschaffung der kostenlosen steht fest
was hast du auch ein fehler sicher nicht
nur wir hätten uns all diese probleme
schnell testen her booster impfung hin
oder her auch nicht wenn wir nicht
diejenigen dazu gebracht hätten sich
impfen zu lassen die sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen und die tragen ich bleibe
dabei die verantwortung im sinne der
nicht begriffen hat bisher das kona
gefährlich ist und dass er mit einer
nicht impfung andere tatsächlich auch
gefährdet der ist in der tat um es mit
dem früheren bundespräsidenten zu sagen
bekloppt hier möchte ich ganz kurz weil
du hast ja auch den teil mit den
intensivbetten hier möchte ich meine
zahl reinbringen weil du hast eben sehr
gerne im europäischen vergleich genügend
intensivbetten ähnliches gehört
einheimischen vergleich mehr intensiv
bilden als in anderen vielen anderen wir
haben etwas über 25.000 das habe ich
halt noch mal nachgeguckt und schon
endet 2018 dabei übrigens cola noch sehr
weit entfernt hat zum beispiel auch
schon die ärzte zeitung darauf
hingewiesen dass es eng werden könnte
mit den intensivbetten damals war es
aufgrund der grippe also ich glaube
definitiv und das frage ich mich das ist
meine frage die ich heute die runde
mitgebracht habt weil ich mich schon so
lange frage wie konnte es uns denn nicht
gelingen jetzt mal in den letzten zwei
jahren die pandemie 22 jahre alt mal
anzufangen intensivbetten aufzubauen und
natürlich am anzufangen mehr personal
auszubilden und da muss ich sagen mir
jetzt ist kommt jetzt wahrscheinlich das
gegenargument naja da die rennen ja alle
weg aus der pflege wenn man mal
ordentlich geld in die hand nehmen würde
dann würde man doch auch menschen finden
die intensivpfleger werden wollen würde
das ist einfach nur zu schlecht bezahlt
ganz so einfach mit den intensivbetten
ist es auch wieder nicht wir haben
mindestens 28.000 die intensivbetten
werden geschaffen und wieder
zurückgeführt weil es einfach sehr teuer
ist sie zu unterhalten und wenn das
infektionsgeschehen zurückgeht dann baut
man auch als klinik wieder
intensivbetten ab und verwandelt die in
ganz normalen betten die man dann auch
belegen kann und baut sie dann wieder
auf das hängt auch mit der finanzierung
zusammenspannen ganz interessante
anreize schaffen wenn man 75 prozent
auslastung hatte bekam man 50.000 euro
pro bett da haben also alle kliniken
versucht weil diese 75 prozent
auslastung zu halten aber wenn die dann
überfüllt waren haben sie wieder noch
mehr aufgestockt damit mehr geld
bekommen haben alles geschenkt die mit
den ungewöhnlich dass mit den
ungeimpften macht man sich aber zu
einfach es ist ein sehr kleiner pool von
leuten die noch nicht das erste mal
geimpft sind und sich auch notorisch
weigern normalerweise würde das in einer
durch geimpften gesellschaft einfach
weggedrückt nur ein kino voll hass und
das jetzt ein ungeimpfter drin der hat
sich angesteckt die anderen sind alle
gefällt das überhaupt nicht auf der kann
keine anstecken das problem ist dass wir
aber auch nicht wissen ob die geimpften
nicht so ein kleines virus auf der
schulter sitzen haben was dann drüber
springt also auch die geimpften können
träger des virus sein haben wir uns oft
nicht gedacht also die die lage ist sehr
viel unübersichtlicher
nun kann man ja sagen okay aus
psychologischen gründen machen wir druck
auf die einige im direktiven müssen wir
direkt schon da müssen wir direkt etwas
klasse weil das ist ja das ist leider
ein teil der der verunsicherung die
entsteht indem man so ein bisschen
hinterher schiebt ja auch wer geimpft
ist der kann corona kriegen das ist die
wahrheit aber die auswirkungen sind doch
bei den meisten die korona bekommen wenn
sie geimpft sind ganz anders als berlin
und leben auch schon über das muss der
abstimmung gestellt und schon ist er
optionen grund dafür wir haben ihn um
den lohn weiter
zur schule aber schöne ist wir bleiben
beim thema corona sein